ce sport cette petite rengaine bien
misogyne a pris ses racines il ya fort
longtemps en 1941 le football est
interdit aux femmes françaises car jugé
trop dangereux et surtout susceptible de
favoriser l'émancipation
alors pas étonnant en 1955 alors que la
pratique du foot féminin reprend tout
doucement d'entendre ce genre de sujet
quant à la lutte pour la balle elle ne
dépasse jamais pour ses ballerines du
football le classique entre chats poésie
un peu lourdingue
non non c'est bien de la misogynie enfin
il faut comprendre que tu es le gardien
de but ne peut plonger car elle
rebondirait temps à l'autre sont un
défrisage lui interdit de faire une tête
et puis tout compte fait pourquoi ne pas
rentrer à la maison faire le ménage
quinze ans après ce magnifique sujet
télé en 1970 le football féminin est
reconnue par la fédération française
mais le sexisme est encore très présent
cette époque les journalistes sportifs
n'ont alors qu'une seule question à la
bouche
est-ce que vous pensez que le football
est compatible avec l'évanouissement
notre féminité
bien sûr trois ans plus tard même
question aux joueuses de l'équipe de
france on va lui demander quand même se
tourner vers les caméras
merci mademoiselle on met une mèche
parce que la féminité ne perd pas ses
droits
je pensais que c'est compatible je vous
football et garder sa féminité
bien sûr on n'a pas l'air féminine mais
le journaliste sportif des années 70
veut comprendre
une seule explication envisageable elles
doivent être revendicatrice militante
est-ce qu'à naître quelques unes qui
appartiennent aux mêmes élèves et non
raté il faudra attendre les années 80
pour un premier coup de gueule à la télé
une journaliste s'insurge contre la
misogynie dont sont victimes les
footballeuses vos football aux
françaises qui ont rencontré leur
hygiène week-end ont été battus 3 0 et
me sens belle où elles sont belles et
puis je voudrais vous que remonter ce
soir je voudrais carré de cette
misogynie
parce que c'est complètement ridicule
mais ce coup de gueule n'empêchera pas
de nouvelles manifestations sexiste la
preuve en 2017 avec des banderoles
misogyne au parc de l'olympique lyonnais
un choc pour les joueuses de ce club
élite du football féminin en france en
tant que femme et surtout en tant que
joueuse l'olympique lyonnais c'est vrai
que c'est pas c'est pas bienvenu avant
nous il ya des générations qui ont
galéré pour ce faire tout simplement
une place dans la société et c'est vrai
que d'en arriver à chaque fois à
repartir de entre guillemets 2 0 ben
ouais ça fait un moment
voilà on en 2017 il faudrait bien que
les mentalités changent
les autorités du foot espère que cette
coupe du monde organisée en france fera
évoluer les mentalités
un mois avant la compétition certes un
match affichait déjà complet
c'est un premier signal
[Musique]